you all seem too young to have known
Gilda personally I'm just gonna make
that leap so where did your lives
intersect at what point and basically
why Gilda like what was it that made you
three wanted to make her a part of your
life and fight for her well about seven
years ago I started doing fundraising
videos for Gilda's Club in New York City
so Gilda's Club is a place for people
with cancer that was founded by Gene
Wilder and killed his friends after um
passed away and I just fell in love with
Gilda's Club itself and you walk into
Gilda's Club and those murals of Gilda
so I started to read her book and when I
would interview the members for these
fundraising videos they would talk about
Gilda as if she was a friend
they really identified with what she was
going through and I just thought her
legacy was really unique cuz her place
in comedy is is pretty solid but she
also has a really amazing legacy in a
world of cancer where she really helps
many many people so my family is
actually close friends with the Radner
family and has been since long before I
was born so I knew Gilda when I was a
kid and have no memories of her and she
sent presents and was just the loveliest
friend and her brother Michael is my
godfather so of course when Lisa started
making the film he reached out to me and
let me know that she was making it and
when we finally had a chance to meet it
I saw the assembly cut of the film and
just was so relieved at what a beautiful
and brilliant job Lisa had done and just
as someone who you know coming from the
front perspective I was just really
amazed and just and relieved just that
she had done such a great job and with
such sensitive topics of the ups and
downs of her life so I knew I wanted to
help her in whatever way she she wanted
so and James I was lucky enough to see
Gilda on Broadway as a young kid my
brother's took me to see her and I
became instantly I felt instantly in
love with her her spirit her childlike
qualities
and to just to see her create all of
those characters these beautifully
imperfect human beings I related to
Emily Litella on some level and Judy
Miller and and and certainly the nerd
lisa loopner like i wanted to be loved
and i wanted to be heard so i was a
fanboy from from way back when
and got it got to go back backstage
snapped the picture with her or four of
her and got her autograph and that was
it I couldn't talk to her I see that she
was larger than life and my I can hear
my brothers in the background I gave me
on say something but that wasn't gonna
happen and and then it changed my life
it changed my professional life didn't
know it at the time but I'd be connected
to her and various projects I when I
started watching it I didn't know that
Gilda would be talking to me and I
literally just went it took my breath
away and I was like I was startled and
then immediately comforted and just it
was just like this wonderful connection
and I thought okay the first question
I'm gonna ask is how did those audio
files come to you what are they really
cuz is it like this you know the
Watergate tapes are these the little
cassette tapes that you you got a stash
of and you found and was that early on
or did that happen later in the process
or well what you're looking at is about
18 different sources of tapes okay but
the way it started was about halfway
through the project I was sort of
shooting and raising money and shooting
and taking time off and Gilda's brother
gave me access to her boxes that had
been in storage and in those boxes were
and they were like 35 boxes it wasn't it
was like his stuff his mother's stuff
Gilda stuff and in it
there was a tape that I was looking for
cuz in Gilda's book she talked about
some of the things she had filmed and
she filmed her ninth chemotherapy video
and that's what I really wanted to find
so the first trip to Detroit we were
able to find that tape and you see that
in the film okay
so then with that it was really
overwhelming how much stuff was there
because they were just overwhelming but
I have remembered seeing a box of tapes
in there and in Gilda's book she talked
about making the ninth chemotherapy but
in her audio but she did an audiobook of
her book and that wasn't in there so I
said to Michael there was a box of tapes
can you send me the box of tapes and I
thought they were the the Masters for
the audiobook but they were actually the
the way Gilda wrote her book it's always
something is she would record her life
story to both her audio her cassette
player and she would sit with somebody
and just talk over a period of months so
those I had so I had 32 hours of audio
tape of Gilda telling her story Wow but
they were extremely damaged so the audio
was really really bad so the first
rendition of the film was the first
assembly of the film was using all that
bad audio mm-hmm so it was a very it was
a similar film but it was just with a
really bad audio and my filmmaker
friends were saying well it's okay
because it's gold of telling her story
and my regular friends were like you
can't have a film like this because no
one wants to read subtitles well they're
watching a film so then we all went on a
mission to find interviews that she had
done that we can't Meryl found from her
her University of Michigan you get to
tell stories yeah they were at the
Michigan daily and just happened to
interview her and so Lisa was like well
that's if they have audio too because
they had pictures and they're like
actually yeah we recorded our interview
with her and we have the audio tape it
was it was two college students who came
to SNL and they they interviewed her and
they kept the tape all forty-something
years later so some of the that is their
tape and then there's some other sources
like that so but that was really the
goal was to have Gil to tell her story
you folded in of course not only the
recollections of her colleagues and the
people who knew her in her lifetime
but then this one
full lens of what we would call you know
the comics of today you know and the
people that maybe didn't know her or
knew her as a child but are influenced
by her the the modern-day comics that
you have reading her journal and talking
about her so was that part of the
initial spine of the story that you
developed did you always sort of want to
have like the historical recollections
mirroring against the current day
influences I to me the film was always
always about legacy so I thought that
would be really important to show that
and to show guiltless place in comedy
whereas Gilda was influenced by Lucille
Ball and Charlie Chaplin and all these
people she goes on to influence Amy and
Tina Fey and most McCarthy who are
influencing now the new generation you
know new so I wanted to show her place
yeah it was important and I liked that
it wasn't just gender specific that you
know bill was there too and well that
thanks to James because I was the guy it
has to be feel hate her so much
childlike quality in his work truly
maybe not him Barry so much but if you
look at the SNL clips it's he's he's got
that little little boy in him what would
you say that she has taught you
personally what's your takeaway I say
keep the child in you alive always there
was always a big part of all of her
characters so I try to act like a big
kid all the time till the bitter end
yeah she did that I would say just her
bravery when faced with cancer and
life's challenges and how humor got her
through it and it's you seeing it on
screen was is really amazing as I've
heard stories of how brave she was but I
just I can't I rarely have seen I mean
ever anyone so brave with cancer and to
do it on screen and it's just
inspirational to me for you know and I
think other people are getting that too
so yeah I would say similar finding what
I was always impressed by Gilda is that
she could find the humor in the darkest
of times and
I wish I could do that you know you
that's like it's really hard I know I
try it's really hard and also she never
apparently she never forgot anybody's
birthday oh that's a gift yeah that's a
good size started putting in the
calendar like you know every year so
that I will start to remember birthday
so that's it yeah
thank you all very much thank you so
much